[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is cs50 harvard university's
introduction to the intellectual
enterprises of computer science and the
art of programming
my name is david malen and if you are
among those in the room who are thinking
why am i in a class of computer science
realize that i too felt that exact same
way in fact my freshman year i
didn't quite get up the nerve to take
this class or computer science more
generally and that was largely because i
was
intimidated by it i was a little nervous
it felt well
out of my comfort zone and i really
didn't know at the end of the day
what it actually was but realize if you
two are feeling a little bit of that or
even if you're among those more
comfortable who have dabbled in computer
science
or programming realize that there's so
many blanks that we can fill in along
the way
so that ultimately at the end of the
semester everyone will feel themselves
on the same page and until then rest
assured that 68
of the people sitting to your left and
to your right and behind and in front
have never taken a cs course before uh
which may very well be
the demographic into which you fit but
realize too
that uh with such an amazing support
structure with so many office hours and
sections and materials and beyond
realize that what's ultimately important
in this course is not so much where you
end up
relative to your classmates in week 10
our final week but where you end up
relative to yourself
in week zero and indeed that is where we
now are and as it turns out computer
scientists start counting at zero
and so over the next 11 weeks will we
take you from being
among those less comfortable or perhaps
somewhere in between less comfortable
and more
to feeling much more comfortable and
confident and capable
than that but to get there we need to
understand what computer science really
is and this was something i didn't
understand until i set foot in a room
like this
and i dare say we can distill computer
science into just this picture
computer science is about problem
solving and i know that high school
courses
typically do kind of paint a misleading
picture that it's only about and it's
entirely about
programming and people with their heads
down in the computer lab working fairly
anti-socially on code
but the reality is it's all about
solving problems and very often solving
problems collaboratively either in
person or by leveraging
code programs that others have written
in the past and what does it mean to
solve a problem
well you need inputs so there's a
problem you're trying to solve that is
the input
and you want output you want the
solution to that problem and the sort of
secret sauce of computer science
is going to be everything in this
proverbial black box in the middle
that over the next several weeks where
you begin to understand exactly
what you can do with that but in order
to start solving problems we kind of
just need to decide as a group like how
we're going to represent
these problems and what might a problem
be well in this room there's a whole
bunch of people if we wanted to
take attendance or count the number of
people in this room i might need to
start
keeping track of how many people i see
but how do i represent the number of
people i see
well i can do it sort of old school and
i can just take out a piece of chalk or
whatnot and say alright i see one
two three four five i can do little
stylistic conventions like that to save
space or remind myself one
six seven eight nine ten and so forth
or i can of course just do that on my
own uh hand so 1
2 3 4 5 and so forth but obviously
how high can i count on just one hand
so 5 you would think but that's just
because we haven't really thought hard
enough about this problem it turns out
that with just these five fingers let
alone these five more
i can actually count rather higher
because after all the system i'm using
of hash marks on the board or just now
with my fingers
is just kind of keeping my fingers down
or putting them up to represent
ones really but what if i actually took
into account the order of my fingers and
sort of permuted them so to speak
so that it's really patterns of fingers
that represent the number of people in
the room and not just the mere presence
of a finger going up or down
in other words this can remain zero this
could still be one
but what if two is not just this the
obvious
but what if it's just this so raising
just one my second finger
what if then three is this so we have 0
1 2 3 that's going to lead us to
4 somewhat offensively but if we can
jump ahead to
5 5 i might now permute this finger and
this finger up and if i want to now
represent
six i could do this and now seven in
other words i've expressed so many more
patterns on my hand already
and if we keep doing this i think i can
actually represent painfully perhaps
like 32 different patterns and therefore
32 different people
on my hands alone or 31 people if i
start counting at zero
so but what is that what's the
relationship and how did we even get
here well turns out that computers
are kind of simplistic much like our
hands here at the end of the day your
computer is plugged into the wall or
it's got a battery so it's either has
or it does not have electricity at the
end of the day that is the physical
resource that drives these things and
our phones and all of technology today
so if there's either electricity or not
that kind of maps nicely to no finger
or yes finger and indeed computers as
you probably know only speak what
what language what alphabet so to speak
yeah binary by meaning two and indeed
that refers to the fact that in binary
in computers
you only have two digits zero and one we
humans of course have zero one two three
four five six seven eight nine
and then we can combine those to count
even higher but computers only have zero
one
and then that's it because at the end of
the day there's actually a direct
mapping between
power being off and it being a zero or
power being on and it being one or some
electrons or whatever flowing
from your battery or from the wall so
this is why computers tend to speak
only binary because at the end of the
day it just maps really cleanly
to what it is that's powering them in
the first place
but how is this actually useful if
computers only have zeros and ones how
can they do anything useful
well think about our human world where
you might have
this pattern of symbols this is decimal
deck meaning 10 because you have 0
through 9
and this is of course 123. but why if
you haven't thought about this in quite
some time
this is really just a pattern of three
symbols one and two and three
shapes or glyphs on the screen but we
humans ever since grade school have
started ascribing meaning to each of
these numbers right
if you think back this is the ones
column this is the tens column
this is the hundreds column and so forth
and we could keep going
and so why does this pattern one two
three mean 123
well it's because all of us sort of
intuitively nowadays are just quickly in
our head doing 100 times 1
plus 10 times 2 plus 1
times 3 which of course gives us 100
plus 20
plus 3 and then the number we know
mathematically as
123. but we're all doing this so quickly
you don't really
think about this anymore well computers
work fundamentally the same way
they don't have as many digits 0 through
9 as we do
they only have zeros and ones and so if
they were to store values you're only
going to see zeros and ones on the
screen but those zeros and ones just
mean different things
instead of having a ones place tens of
hundreds they're going to have a ones
place
a twos place a fourth place and then 8
and 16 and
and beyond now why well 1 and 10 and 100
turns out those are powers of 10. 10 to
the 0
is technically 1. 10 to the 1 is just 10
10 to the 2
is 100 and that's why you have ones tens
hundreds thousands and so forth
computers are apparently using powers of
two not surprising binary two
so if you only have uh ones twos and
fours as your placeholders
if a computer we're storing these
digits zero zero zero that computer is
presumably storing
what number so far as we humans
understand it
well that's how a computer would store
zero if a computer is storing literally
zero zero zero
just like in our human world that also
is zero but that's technically because
it's four times zero
plus two times 0 plus 1 times 0 which is
obviously 0.
meanwhile if a computer is actually
storing not just
say 0 0 0 but instead of storing this
value in binary
what does that map to in decimal so
that's one
and now why if we change this
uh zero and one to this value here
is this two well mathematically for the
exact same reasons
and so earlier i had five fingers but if
you consider just my first three
when i did this holding up one finger i
was representing
two and if i want to represent three
recall that i put up the second finger
and so the reason that could nicely
represent three
is because all i was doing with my human
hand was counting
in binary and i could keep counting more
and more and more and so if i have
five fingers or five bits bit meaning
binary digit
i could count up it turns out if we do
the math as high as 31
by starting to zero it's going to be
hard to physically do that but we could
so why is this useful at the end of the
day a computer therefore
can represent any number of values from
zero to one to two to three to
some number much much much higher than
that all it needs is enough bits enough
zeros and ones well what are those bits
well all of us have these days in our
phones sources of light for instance so
i could actually say that this physical
device right now might be a little hard
to tell
it does have a flashlight and it's
technically off at the moment but if i
turn this flashlight on
thereby using some of the electricity
then now i'm storing a one
and so the phone is on now it's off now
it's on and if i
see can i borrow someone's phone real
quick may i okay
and flashlight how do i turn on the
flashlight
oh shake it
that's okay okay thank you that's it oh
thank you
okay so this is great now i can count
higher so now i'm counting
now this represents the number what if i
have two light bulbs or two switches on
at the moment
yeah three because i have a one i have a
one and i have a two which of course is
going to end up equaling three and if i
pick up a third phone somehow
i could count even higher technically if
i had three light bulbs on
one one one what would that value be
seven because it's a four plus a two
plus a one
and so forth thank you so much for the
spontaneity so
why does this not lead to limitations
for us i can count
in a decimal as high as i want i can now
count in binary as high as i want so
long as i have enough bits
but how do i actually represent other
information
well if i want to represent something
like a letter how do i get there
if computers only have electricity in
them and they use binary to count
and yet somehow they're much more useful
than just doing math they can have text
messages and emails and websites and
videos and more
how do we get from zeros and ones to
letters well we shoot yeah
sorry a little louder yeah we just need
to kind of relate the numbers to letters
in other words all the people in this
room
just need to decide at some point that
you know what if we want to represent
something like the capital letter a
we just need to decide on a pattern of
bits a pattern of fingers
that's going to represent a and it turns
out humans years ago
just unilaterally decided 65 shall be
the decimal number
that represents capital letter a and you
might guess capital b is represented by
what decimal number
66 and then c is 67 and so forth and
there's a mapping
of like 128 or even 256 possible values
for all the keys you might see on a
typical keyboard
in order to represent letters now how
does a computer distinguish though
numbers from letters well it just
depends on the context if you're using
like a calculator program on your mac or
pc or iphone or android
well the computer the device is just
going to know contextually
let me interpret this pattern of zeros
and ones as actual numbers to do math
but if you're using the sms app or the
messages app on your phone
you're going to actually be in the
context of text and so your phone
is going to interpret that same pattern
of zeros and ones or light bulbs being
off
or at the end of the day transistors
tiny pieces of hardware and computers
that are either on
or off it's going to interpret those
patterns as just representing a letter
if you're in the context of
a text messaging application or
microsoft word or google docs or the
like
it completely depends on context the
system we humans came up with
just called ascii american standard code
for information interchange
the name isn't interesting but the fact
that we all agreed years ago
that 65 is a and so forth is what's
important
and so for instance if we look at this
mapping here of just the first few
letters
what does this mean if i were to now
get a text message and i had the ability
somehow to look underneath the hood so
to speak at the pattern of zeros and
ones that someone had just texted me
and that pattern if i convert it to
decimal technically said
uh let's say 72 and 73. so i get a whole
bunch of zeros and ones
i do some math and i realize okay i just
received 72 and 73
but this is texting and so it's not just
numbers my friend is sending me it's a
message
what message did my friend likely send
me if he or she sent
72 and then 73.
yeah hi h i because if you skim ahead at
the right there
that just happens to be in ascii the
mapping between
72 and 73 to h and i if technically the
message had a third
byte if you will a byte if you've ever
wondered it's just
eight bits it's convenient to talk not
in terms of single bits where you can't
count very high
but with a byte or eight bits you can
count higher and so
it turns out if i received a third byte
another sequence of eight zeros and ones
together
33 how would we know what this message
now is
yeah so it turns you would not know this
other than by guessing or googling or
just coming in with this knowledge this
is now
high with an exclamation point because
33 just so happens if you look it up
to map to an exclamation point as well
now if we actually looked at the binary
of this you would actually see this
pattern of zeros and ones this is how
you represent 72 in binary this is how
you represent 73
and this is how you represent 33 and
notice i've only used one
two three four five six bits even though
i technically tend to receive things in
units of eight units of bytes
but why did i not bother writing another
zero zero here and another zero here
does it matter when you write these
things out
no not really like in in english in our
human world if you were to write one
one two three that's 123 if you were to
write zero one two three
that's still 123. so even though we tend
to get them in
uh clusters of eight we don't
necessarily need to write those when
just talking about them
so what have we done well let me
introduce a fancy word now known as
abstraction abstraction
is just a term generally used in
computer science and we'll soon see in
programming
for taking some low level like literally
low level
implementation details like minutiae
even
and understanding them at some point but
then deciding this is not a useful
level conceptually to think about
problems i really don't want to solve
problems in this world
thinking in zeros and ones i'd much
rather think about things
minimally in decimal or better yet in
the context of letters if i'm actually
receiving text or even some other
representation
so abstraction is about taking fairly
low level details
and just simplifying them so that we can
have a more useful conversation and
never again worry about where the
electricity is coming from we can just
stipulate
my computer can represent zeros and ones
therefore can represent numbers
therefore can also represent ascii
or letters and we can kind of move on
and start solving more interesting
problems
but it would seem that we can't solve
all problems
because on my keyboard here this
american keyboard here
there's a whole bunch of symbols like
100 or two maybe in total if we actually
hit shift and option and all that
but what you don't see are some pretty
common characters especially in a very
international audience what can i
apparently not even type on this
keyboard
what kinds of symbols yeah anything with
an accent if you have accents over
vowels or other letters what else
i'm sorry um lots or other characters
above letters yeah
pound uh pound like pound symbol oh like
the uk pound symbol sure in other
countries too
any number of asian languages there's so
many symbols that are not depicted on
this keyboard and yet somehow
all of us with international keyboards
or phones can surely express themselves
but that's because phones and computers
these days don't just use ascii
ascii literally used just eight bits
total technically seven but then
ultimately really eight
and with eight bits if you actually do
the math if you have eight bits or eight
fingers you can only permute them in 256
total possible ways which is to say that
you can only represent 256
characters using ascii with by with
numbers underneath the hood and that's
not enough to
represent so many different symbols like
those enumerated here
you can't represent any of the accents
that you can nonetheless type on your
macs and pcs and you certainly
can't type these things which are very
much in vogue which even though they're
pictures
they're actually just characters because
it turns out some years ago
the world decided eight bits is not
enough let's start using something
called unicode
where you actually use one or two or
three or even four
bytes so 8 bits or 16 bits 24 bits or
even 32
bits to represent characters and now we
have the ability to represent
thousands or even millions of characters
and frankly dare say
the result of that huge amount of
availability is partly why there are so
many of these things these days and they
just keep making more because there's
just so many different numbers available
to us so unicode is often a specific
version of it called
utf-8 which we'll see before long but
let me ask this question here
this is a crying face with joy
i think this is called so it turns out
according to apple or ios this is the
most popular emoji that at least iphone
people are sending to each other
so when you're receiving this though if
we can really take the fun out of this
what pattern of bits are you actually
receiving from your friend
he or she is clearly trying to express
some emotion but
really what your friend is sending you
the decimal number 128
514 or really if you looked at the zeros
and ones coming out to you over the
internet or
airwaves you're getting this pattern of
zeros and ones which is hardly joyful
or hardly descriptive but all your phone
or computer are doing is seeing this
pattern of bits
looking it up in like a little cheat
sheet and saying oh whenever i see this
pattern of bits in the context of text
like texting i should actually display
it as that picture
now that picture has a lot of yellow and
other colors in it
but how do we even get there well it
turns out that this same pattern of
numbers
72 73 33 which just to be sure a moment
ago meant what
hi in the context of a textual program
like microsoft word google docs texting
this means hi but what if you saw this
same pattern of
bytes and again we could draw the zeros
and ones but it's not interesting
anymore so we're going to abstract away
at the decimal level if you've got the
same pattern of zeros and ones or
or numbers in the context of like
photoshop or a browser
or some kind of photo program well it
might make more sense to interpret it
not as text
but as imagery some kind of colors well
it turns out there's this other system
in the world you might have seen this
acronym before
called rgb red green blue and this is
just a way
of humans having standardized years ago
that you know what if we want to
represent a dot on someone's screen
otherwise known as a pixel tiny little
square on the screen of your phone your
laptop or even tv these days
we're gonna use three bytes one byte to
specify how much red
should be in that specific pixel uh one
more byte to specify how much green
should be combined with red to form that
pixel and then one more byte a third
to represent how much blue to combine
with those other two colors to make
a new color all together so it's kind of
like combining paints
except in this case it's more really
waves of light
in order to get a specific color using
just red green and blue
as your palette and so if we were to see
this
red green blue pattern and say you know
what give me 72 red
73 of green and 33 of blue
if the total possible range as i alluded
to earlier is like 0 to 256 or
technically 0
to 255 if you start counting in computer
science like from zero
this is like a medium amount of red
medium amount of green and just a little
bit of blue if the range goes from zero
to 255
so if you combine these three things
together anyone know what color you get
yeah so it's kind of a y light yellow
that looks like this so if a computer
is storing a single dot on the screen
that happens to be in yellow
what the computer is actually storing is
not this dot physically
but a pattern of three bites how much
red how much green how much blue should
the computer display at this particular
point
so if we look at this crying face of joy
and we kind of enhance or zoom in on it
here
you can actually see it start to
pixelate so to speak where you start to
see the dots if i punch in a little more
now you can really start to see the dots
on the screen and if i go in
even farther you can actually see the
tiny little squares that compose this
image
most of which at the zoom level are
yellow but a bunch of which are
black a bunch of which are like light
black or
dark yellow and that's what composes
this image ultimately
so this is to say if you count up all of
the pixels on the screen
and then multiply it by one two three
bytes that's how many bytes or kilobytes
or megabytes if you've heard those terms
are going to be stored on your computer
just to represent
that image so we've gone from
electricity
to down here so to speak to zeros and
ones to decimal now to colors
well with colors you can get images what
comes after images well we've all
watched videos or movies certainly
digitally these days
well what is a movie or a video file how
might that be implemented
yo show you a little ladder yeah it's a
collection of images if you've ever
heard of frames per second like movies
tend to be 24 frames per second or 30
frames per second
that just means that a typical movie
every second is showing you 24 or 30
images per second and they're just
flying by so quickly
that you actually don't notice you're
just watching a sequence of static
images it's like as a kid if you ever
had one of those paper
flip books where there's tons of
drawings in them and as you flip through
the pages
you see things moving but that's just
because your eyes are just seeing little
snapshots ever so quickly
of something moving on the paper that's
all a video file actually is
so if you have an iphone and you've ever
played with these animojis so to speak
well all those are our little video
files composed of
lots and lots and lots of images that
you have saved on your phone
or texted to someone else and if we just
think now okay now we're at the point of
video but that's okay videos are just
bunches of images
images are just bunches of colors colors
are just patterns of bits and bits
at the end of the day are just the
result of electricity coming into my
machine or
transistors turning switches on and off
like we've all of a sudden told like
this entire story
but none of us ever is going to need to
really think about binary in the context
of videos
because a video is just an abstraction
on top of bunches of images and images
are just an abstraction of top bunches
of
pixels and so forth so we can keep
painting this hierarchy
that just allows us to talk about things
at a more useful level and the reason we
had this conversation
is just because we needed a way to
represent inputs
and outputs to problems so let me pause
there for just a second
to see if there's any questions anything
at all
no all right so what's inside this this
black box well it turns out
this is where the really interesting
work starts to happen and the thought
starts to come in this is the proverbial
algorithms step-by-step instructions
for solving some problem and some of you
might have solved this problem before
either digitally or textually but of
course if
you have like contacts in your phone
these days and you've got bunches of
friends and family odds are they're
alphabetized by first name or last name
and
you have autocomplete these days but it
really is just a long list of names and
numbers
that's not all that different from
yesteryear's implementation of the same
problem
which was this device here a phone book
now this phone book might have a friend
of ours in it say
mike smith whose last name starts with s
and i could of course if trying to find
mike smith
start by looking at the first of the
page the second page
the third page the fourth page and
eventually just
hopefully find mike smith indeed is this
algorithm this step-by-step process
correct for finding someone like mike
smith
yeah it's correct it's stupid and slow
perhaps because it's going to take
forever
in a phone book of this size but it is
correct because if mike's in here i will
in fact find him but i could do this
better i could do it sort of two at a
time so
two four six eight ten imperfectly 10
12 14. is that faster
obviously it's going twice as fast is it
correct
no why is it not correct yeah i might
miss him right mike just accidentally
might eventually get sandwiched between
two pages and i have the unlucky
experience
of just missing him now is it fixable
yeah i can probably once i hit like
s n or the t section for instance i can
just say all right obviously i've gone
too far for mike
let me just double back one or just a
few pages so it is fixable
and so long as i've saved time by flying
through this twice as fast
can i at least afford to spend a few
more steps at the very end just to find
mike smith but none of us are going to
do that and our apple devices and
android devices certainly don't do that
for efficiency today
odds are most of us are going to do what
to find someone in any book like this
yeah open to you know roughly the middle
or maybe buy us ourselves toward the end
because s is after the middle but you
know i'm in the middle of the phone book
here and now if i
know that mike is in the s's and
therefore over here where do i know he's
not
he's not in the beginning and i can
literally tear a problem like this in
half
throw figuratively and literally half of
the problem away and be left with
fundamentally the same problem but it's
half as big i went from like whatever a
thousand pages to 500 pages
and i can now repeat this algorithm i
look down and a little too far i'm in
the t
section now okay i can again tear the
problem in half
throw that half away taking a 500 page
bite out
a 250 page bite out now leaving myself
with just 250 pages more
and notice just how quickly i got here
the first two algorithms got me from a
thousand to 999 to 998
or a thousand to 998 to 996
but here i went from a thousand to 500
to 250 feels like we're making up
time here and indeed if i keep repeating
this process hopefully
i'll be left with just one page of the
book that mike is either on or not
at which point i will call him and so
that's an algorithm that honestly
leverages probably all the intuition we
have
and a lot of what programming is going
to be is thinking about a problem like
this
figuring out how to divide and conquer
it and then expressing yourself in a way
that the computer can then solve that
problem for you
and just to take paint a picture of how
much better this algorithm
is well if this is just a very abstract
chart where we have on the vertical or
y-axis how much time it takes to solve a
problem
and on the horizontal axis how big the
problem is so
the farther out you go this way the more
pages in the problem the more pages in
the phone book and the higher you go up
here the more seconds or page turns it's
going to take
that first algorithm is just like a
linear slope
so to speak because for every additional
page in the book it might take me one
more second
right up right up it's just a one for
one relationship with pages
the second algorithm if i plot it where
i'm flying through twice as fast what is
that line going to look like instead
yeah a little it's going to look lower
than this one it's still going to be a
straight line because now there's a two
to one relationship
but if you've got a phone book that's
got this many pages and in the
first algorithm it took this long here
well in the second algorithm it's going
to take about it will take half
as many steps plus or minus one or two
if you need to actually double back a
little bit
but that third algorithm is what we'll
call logarithmic if n is the number of
pages in the phone book
the first algorithm in the very worst
case might take all in pages to find
mike smith
the second algorithm is going to take
half as many steps because i'm flying
through it two at a time
but the third algorithm is going to look
and feel like this it's going to be
curved and ever so slowly rising and
rising and rising the implication of
which is
if verizon or the phone company doubles
the number of pages in the phone book
next year because
cambridge and somerville merge together
in the phone book and we now have 2 000
pages well how many
more steps does my third algorithm take
just one because i can take a thousand
page byte out of the problem with that
clever
algorithm whereas my first two
algorithms would take it one or just two
pages at a time
so that is to say we have to hugely
increase the size of this problem
just for the number of seconds or page
turns to appreciably
actually increase and so as we start to
learn about programming it's again going
to be leveraging of this intuition
in order to actually solve problems in
code
more effectively than we might uh
without code alone or without
that intuition alone so let's formalize
this now
so that was kind of a very intuitive way
of dividing and conquering a problem
just kind of made sense to go in the
middle
tear it then go to the other half or the
other half and tear it again and
and so forth but a computer even as cool
as
alexa and google home and all this are
you can't really just talk to them as
another human and have them execute
things correctly i struggle just to get
uh siri to like set a timer on my phone
so we're not quite there yet so
we're still at the age where we have to
be ever so precise with computers
voice activated or otherwise and so thus
enter pseudo code for now
pseudocode has no formal definition this
is just a way of saying use english like
syntax or any
uh spoken language and just express
yourself succinctly
and correctly so that a computer or
robot or even another person
can understand what it is you're trying
to say so here
i propose is an algorithm written in
pseudocode english like syntax
that just gets my point across and i
could write this in any number of ways
i've numbered the steps from zero on up
just for the sake of discussion
but this would seem to capture what i
did there pick up the phone book
open to the middle of the phone book
look at the names if smith is among the
names call mike
else if smith is earlier in the book go
to the left
specifically the middle of the left half
of the book and then go back to step two
because indeed i was just doing the same
thing again and again and the reason i
wasn't doing it forever was because
every time i repeated myself by opening
and tearing
i was shrinking the problem and i can
only shrink a problem of some fixed
finite size so many times until i get
just one page
and so if i can continue this logic
looking to the right or to the left or
just quitting
if i don't find mic at all on the last
page this would seem to capture more
precisely
that code well let's actually excerpt
from this now a few concepts and now
start and then start to apply them to
actual code
highlighted in yellow here i dares are
all the verbs or actions these are the
functions as we're going to start
calling them in this algorithm a
function
is just a specific step a specific
action you take in order to
do something and so in yellow here pick
up open to look at
call open quit or all actions or verbs
or henceforth we'll call them
functions meanwhile highlighted in
yellow here if else if else if else
these are kind of starting to ask
questions what might these be called if
you have
some familiarity yeah it turns out many
programming languages if you've seen any
before would call these conditions
they're branches
or proverbial forks in the road if this
is true go this way else maybe go this
other way
or perhaps a third or fourth direction
altogether meanwhile
if we actually look at these highlighted
phrases if smith is among names or if
smith is earlier in book or smith is
later in book
these are the specific questions we're
asking in order to make that decision
these are known as boolean expressions
named after a gentleman by the last name
of bull some years ago and so a boolean
expression is just a question that has
a yes no answer a true false answer a
one
zero answer if you will and that's a
nice mapping to what computers are
really good at
so within conditions you have boolean
expressions to decide
which fork in the road you want to go
down and then lastly highlighted in
yellow here
are you go back to step two in a couple
of places this is inducing some kind of
cycle or loop that's telling the
computer to do something again
and again and again so in short we have
these building blocks already
conceptually and it turns out we can now
start to translate these to an actual
programming language the first of the
languages we'll introduce in cs50 is
something called scratch
turns out this is not a text-based
language like in my english pseudocode
there but it's graphical and things look
like puzzle pieces that you can drag and
drop
and they interconnect if it makes
logical sense to do so and in fact some
of you might have played with this back
in the day as kids
or even more recently because it's
actually targeted typically at students
in like after-school programs who just
want to learn more methodical more
algorithmic or computational thinking
and we're going to use it
to explore not only these building
blocks but a few others as well
it turns out in the other languages
we'll explore in cs50 and beyond
are languages like c that will actually
transition to as quickly as next week
to then translate what we do this week
in scratch to next week in c
and in languages like python and
javascript and sql which we'll also
explore
do we have other capabilities the
ability to store data in variables so to
speak
to use threads which means get the
computer to do multiple things at once
events to mean listen for things
happening like a click on the page or a
human typing or even saying something
we'll be able to do all of the things
that you take for granted in your very
own phones and we'll do this first by
way of this guy so this is scratch the
default cat
that comes with this programming
language from mit's media lab and via
scratch can we
start programming him to move up down
left right say something utter something
and other commands all together in fact
let me go ahead and switch contexts here
to show you the very first thing i ever
wrote in scratch it was back in the day
when i was in graduate school and
scratch had just been invented by mit
let me go ahead and open this and uh
i called it oscar time and if we could
perhaps have a volunteer come on up for
just a moment you have to be
comfortable being on stage and on the
internet here in the white shirts
saw your hand first come on down so this
is oscar time
it's implemented in a language called
scratch and at the end of the day
all that is underneath the hood of this
program is functions and loops and
conditions
and a few other of these concepts hi
what's your name aviva aviva david nice
to meet you
come on over here and in just a moment
for coming on up thank you here up aviva
[Music]
a little cs50 stress ball so suffice it
to say if you're tired of this song
consider how tired i was
eight hours later while like debugging
and building this program but consider
what it is we just saw it's this
interactive game and stuff is animated
and music is playing
but if you focus on decomposing so to
speak this program
into just basic building blocks this is
just kind of a big abstraction over some
lower level pieces of functionality like
this trash can here at the moment it's
just a picture
and on occasion as soon as aviva dropped
something into the trash the lid came up
and oscar came out
he said something and then he went back
down but that animation is super
simplistic it was just a sequence of one
two
three or so images displaying and then
going back down to create the illusion
of animation
meanwhile every time oscar said
something that was keeping track of her
score
in what's called a variable in algebra
you have x and y and z
but in programming you have the same
idea but it's generally more useful to
call them
more descriptively like your score and
so there's probably a variable in this
game called
scores that was just keeping track of
how many times a viva had dropped
something into the trash
meanwhile the trash itself and the shoe
and the newspaper and even more things
happen eventually
were falling from the sky at sort of
random locations and that's because i
programmed the game to sort of start the
trash here or over here just to make it
a little more challenging as the game
picked up
and in fact things start falling faster
and faster over time like a typical game
getting more and more difficult so how
do we get to something like that
well let me go ahead and open up scratch
itself and introduce
the environment so in scratch you
essentially have three general areas and
it's web-based and so you can do this on
any computer
and in the left-hand side here you have
those puzzle pieces to which i referred
earlier
these puzzle pieces are all mapping
to functions or loops or conditions or
variables things that we saw before
and i'm going to be able to drag and
drop them into the middle in order to
interconnect them and write my program
which we'll do in just a moment
meanwhile scratch lives in this stage
this world where you can move up down
left right
you can change what scratch looks like
you can add other characters otherwise
known as sprites
in order to have multiple things
happening at once and of course you can
full screen it and so the oscar time
game a moment ago
was actually a whole bunch of sprites
oscar's trash can was one
each piece of trash was another sprite
the newspaper was a sprite and so forth
so each of them were separate programs
running in parallel at the same time
so let's actually make him do something
it turns out
that if i jump down to say events i'm
going to see one of the most powerful
blocks from the gecko
which is this when green flag clicked
that's indeed how i started the game
with aviva by clicking just above
scratch's world
this green flag and if i wanted to stop
it as i did you can click the red stop
sign to say stop
meanwhile the green flag i can
constantly listen for by dragging and
dropping this puzzle piece when the
green flag is clicked what do i want to
do
well let me go up to looks and these are
just different categories and we can
scroll through all the different
colorful blocks but they pretty much
just do what they say
i'm going to go under looks where i know
there to be a block that's called
say and i'm going to go ahead and type
the most canonical computer science
thing hello
world in this box so notice that
functions themselves can actually take
inputs and the input to this function
say is going to be hello world
if i now go over to the green flag and
click it
hello world all right so not all that
difficult not all that
interesting but it actually got the job
done and so my program
is indeed just this well how might i
make this a little more interesting just
saying hello world all the time
isn't all that compelling well you know
what let me think let me undo this
let me scroll down to sensing and notice
this
functions can also take input from the
human and functions can hand you back a
value a so-called return
value so this block here ask something
by default it says what's your name and
weight
is another function built into scratch
that allows me to do this i'm going to
go ahead and drag this here and i'm
going to
let it say what's your name notice now
that below this block is a special block
so that whatever it is the block returns
so answer is whatever the human is going
to type in
and if i want to now save what the human
typed in let me go again to
looks go to say and notice that these
blocks are kind of magnetic they want to
snap together so i'm going to go ahead
and let go there
and if i go back to sensing and grab
answer
notice that even though it's not quite
the same size it's going to grow to fill
and now i can have my program ask the
user what his or her name is
and then say whatever that answer is so
let me go ahead and
stop and click play again notice it's
asking me for my name so let me go ahead
and type in david
enter okay it's a little weird way to
greet someone
david so it'd be nice to clean that up a
bit
so you know what i know this only from
having poked around before not all of
this is obvious at first glance but it
turns out
that under operators the category
there's this thing here join
apple and banana which are just default
values you can change them
because what do i want to do i want to
say hello david or whoever
so i kind of want to say hello comma and
then
david whatever the human typed in and
that's what join lets you do it lets you
join or concatenate
two phrases that are somehow provided by
you or the user so let me
pull this out the answer let me go ahead
and grab the join block notice it too is
going to grow to fill
let me go ahead and say hello comma
space
and now drag answer into there and
notice this
this um this nesting just like in math
this nesting
of functions i can first join hello and
answer
by taking those two things as input and
then pass them to say as another input
because these things are layered on top
and so now if i stop this and play it
again and say david
hello david now we have the makings of a
more interesting interactive program
that isn't just hard coded of course
it's not nearly as
audible as something like the uh
something like oscar time a moment ago
so let me go ahead and do this let me
start over all together
and treat scratch like the cat he is and
just start the sound called meow so it
turns out there's a category of blocks
called
sound and within sound there's play some
defaults down so start sound meow
and now things will get a little cuter
[Music]
and now if i again and i can kind of
simulate a cat by
standing here for a while and keep
clicking this button but you know let me
make a meow a few times because that's
more realistic so let me grab a second
one and a third one and you get this
infinite supply of blocks
let me hit play
seems like a bug let's try again play
[Music]
this is my first bug or mistake this
looks correct it says when green flag
clicked start sound meow
start sound meow start sound meow why am
i only hearing one meow
yeah yeah they're kind of at the same
time
are so close to the same time that the
sounds are kind of tripping over each
other and just overlapping
right the block literally says start
sound meow but computers are really fast
if you've heard of the expression like
gigahertz that's a unit of measure and
if your computer has a one gigahertz
cpu central processing unit or brain
that means it can literally do like a
billion things
per second it can certainly start three
sounds
super fast and if they're effectively
all happening one after the other
before the sound even finishes you're
just hearing one net effect so how can
we fix this
well i can actually go and fix this with
this block here
play sound meow until done play sound
meow until done play sound meow until
done and now
okay it's a little unhappy this
particular cat but at least it's now
more correct and as it turns out
if i go to control you know what i can
there's this block here
weight some number of seconds i can go
ahead and insert this here
let me do another one here and now hit
play
[Music]
yeah it's you know it's not bad it's now
uh
sounds a little more realistic but
honestly if i keep doing this or you
know
you can actually right click or control
click on blocks duplicate them
and just copy and paste even more if you
want them so if i were to do this
now it's just going to go six times and
then i could copy it again and go 12
times but there's got to be a better way
right this is now bad programming this
is bad design
because i'm literally copying and
pasting all biographically but we've
already seen a building block that can
with which we can design this program
better it's correct but it's not well
designed what would the
building block be that i need to make
this a little cleaner
okay a for loop don't quite exist in
scratch but a loop fundamentally
do something cyclically and indeed if i
go under control and start poking around
you'll notice
that there's a few blocks that might
apply here there's the repeat block
some number of times or the forever
block both of which sound like loops
or cycles so sure enough let me go ahead
here and i can throw away blocks by just
dragging them to the left
let me pull this out for a second
and then just say forever play this
sound and then wait one second
so now my program looks like this
yeah we'll never know if it's
technically correct because it's just
going to go
we think forever but it looks like this
is correct and it was a lot less code
and it's a lot easier to maintain
because if i want him to kind of get
sleepy
i can then maybe say two seconds instead
[Music]
you know and we can adjust this on the
fly as we go but let's start to combine
some of these ideas now
and change what it is the or the
ultimate effect is let me go ahead and
open an example i made in advance
this one's called count zero and we'll
put this on the website later so that
you can play with it if you like
and this is kind of the opposite of
counting sheep rather than me or this
person sleeping counting sheep
this sheep will count itself so let me
go ahead and just play
and adorably he seems to just be
counting one two
three but why is that he's just going to
count forever
but let's look at the blocks with which
he's counting forever when green flag
clicked
set counter turns out this orange block
is what we call the variable so an
algebra would be like x or y or z
those are not descriptive i called this
one counter instead but i could have
called it
x or y or z and then i forever say the
counter
for one second then wait one second and
then change the counter by one which
technically means just increment it add
one to it
and the sheep is just going to therefore
count up and up and up now this is a
little tedious but that's kind of the
point of counting sheep
of course to fall asleep but what if
this sheep actually kind of liked
counting a little faster well let me go
into operators here
multiplication sounds like it could get
us places quicker
and let me go ahead and go to variables
and instead of changing the counter by
one let me go ahead and just keep
setting it to something else so let me
drag and drop this
set the counter equal to something times
something
specifically the counter times
two thereby doubling doubling doubling
doubling that would seem to grow so to
speak a lot faster
let's see one
two four
eight so he's counting faster but it's
still kind of tedious what if we instead
do this
let's stop waiting and let's go ahead
and with looks not say counter for one
second but let's just quickly
say counter so i'm going to say the
counter whoops
i'm going to say the counter and then
i'm going to set it to itself times 2.
so here's where we're at
initialize or set the counter to 1
initially say it
then double it then double it then
double it saying it along the way so
here we go
that's impressive
so now the sheep has counted up to 10 to
the 60th
so far 10 to the
100 okay now it doesn't even fit in the
speech bubble
but he's still going how high can he go
what's the biggest number you can count
to in a computer
anyone want to guess
could be here a while 10 to the 270th
now
how high can you count or rather
okay so we gave up and just called it
infinity so it turns out infinity does
have a precise value 10 times
to the 250th or so but what happens here
well because computers at the end of the
day are just storing information
digitally but that information digitally
has to be physically stored using
electricity using these lower level
switches called transistors
at the end of the day my phone my laptop
whatever device in question
only has a finite amount of those things
i only have a finite number of fingers
using unary my old school hash mark
approach i can count to five on this
hand
using binary i claimed i could count to
31
on this hand but it's still finite i
cannot count to infinity on this hand
because i only have five
fingers similarly does a computer only
have so many transistors
or so many bytes or bits of memory and
at some point the programmer
has to think about what is he or she
going to do when the user wants to count
so high that you can't
physically fit it anymore you have to
give up like this and say something
semi-accurately
or you have to handle the issue in some
other way and we'll see when we get to
see
that how you handle this problem is not
necessarily straightforward and indeed a
lot of software out there
does not handle this problem and odds
are all of us have programs that if you
type big enough words or big enough
numbers into them
they might very well break or crash or
freeze because the humans unlike mit did
not anticipate
that that might actually happen and
handle it well let me go ahead and do
this
let me open up this program and see if
we can't read the code now
this is called pet zero and this is a
program
that simulates petting so if i click
play
and don't touch the keyboard nothing
seems to be happening but if i now move
my cursor over to the cat
oh it's kind of cute right now it's more
only meowing on demand
when you pet the cat why well notice
i've added some other building blocks we
haven't used this one before
but it intuitively probably makes pretty
clear sense when the green flag is
clicked
forever do the following if the cat is
touching the mouse pointer this thing in
blue is what we called earlier a boolean
expression it has a yes no a true false
a one zero answer
and touching mouse pointer is one of the
options in the little drop down here if
you tinker with it
so if the cat is touching the mouse
pointer then and only then
play sound meow until done so we've
combined now functions with loops with a
condition
but why the loop the cat's only meowing
once when i pet him
why am i doing anything forever here
uh someone yeah
yeah i might want to pet it again so i
want the program to anticipate that
and honestly if i omitted this forever
block and my program instead looked just
like this so let me get rid of that and
this and then i clicked
play and now i hover over him
why is it not working even once
say again
yeah so i mean at this point if i can
summarize it's
that happen the computer's so damn fast
that this already happened by the time i
move my cursor
over to the cat and at the moment i
clicked play
i was not touching the cat those blocks
executed so to speak top to bottom
that's it for the program
so by the time i move the cursor over to
the cat the program is over it's not
listening and so forever
this way i can actually listen in
perpetuity for something to actually
happen
what if i want to do something not just
if something is true but handle two
cases
if or else well let me go ahead and open
up pet one
and this is another example and could
someone perhaps describe
after reading this code what this
program is going to do instead
exactly and let me summarize more
verbally so if this time you're touching
the cat
it's going to roar instead else it's
just going to
meow sweetly so this time it is meowing
perpetually
once every second but if you touch this
particular cat
he doesn't like it so play meow
meow and now
don't touch the cat so now we might
interact in two different ways by having
two different
roads that you can go down well let's
actually make something a little more
interactive let me go ahead and open
another example
this one called bounce zero because now
we can start to see some design elements
from what oscar time was like this now
is getting a little interesting
what is actually going on here so let me
zoom in on the blocks here
this block is just saying forever move
ten steps which is another block we
haven't seen but 10 steps is like 10
pixels so move
10 pixels on the screen but if you're
touching the edge then turn around 180
degrees and you can see
exactly that happening scratch is
turning around 180 degrees
and this rotation style just means
double back don't like loop around 180
degrees
so that's kind of cool but this is not
how humans or
cats walk like what is obviously
unnatural
about this
yeah i mean i can't even simulate it
right like his feet are in static
position yet sliding back and forth on
the screen
and yet that is not what walking is like
walking presumably has some kind of
movement and what
well we could just kind of simulate it
like okay i could just walk
walking and you can imagine taking like
really quick photographs of my legs or
the cat's leg moving
and then just deciding this photo will
be representative of one step
this photo will be representative of
another and you know with just two of
those steps
i'd wager we could actually do a pretty
good job of simulating what walking
looks like
in fact if i go back to where we began
this picture of scratch
what if i just move his legs ever so
slightly
then go back then go forward and even
just in my pdf i can simulate animation
by hitting up arrow down arrow up arrow
down
arrow because it kind of looks like he's
walking now when really your human eyes
are just seeing two different pictures
again and again so how can i do this
well if i go back to scratch he's still
still walking let me go ahead and open
up
bounce one the second version of this
and now do this okay
so how did i add this there's a little
purple block that we haven't seen yet
but if you poke around the categories
you'll see other blocks like this next
costume that just keeps changing
the costume that he's wearing it turns
out scratch exists as a picture
and his default picture is him not
moving but if i go up here to top left
and click costumes you can actually see
that here's his one costume
here's his second costume and so that
purple block that says next costume
because it's in the forever loop it just
keeps doing next next next next next
just showing one costume or the other
there clearly uh
mimicking walking now this is not very
natural why don't we
slow him down to say five steps at a
time and have him go again
no this is still going pretty fast let
me go ahead and say
we could have control we could have him
wait a second
after moving very dramatically
we should probably speed this up so
let's wait one tenth of a second
point one or maybe that's even let's do
.01 a hundredth of a second now it's
getting a little more realistic but this
is what animation is if you've ever
watched a cartoon or
a movie based on pictures like this
you're just tinkering with some of these
parameters these inputs
in order to produce this output by
understanding what the fundamental
representation of these things is which
in this case are just pictures
again and again and again in order to
create that animation
but what about interactivity let me do
this one myself let me go ahead and get
rid of this
go back to control go back to events and
say when green flag clicked
then let me go ahead and grab a forever
block so that this keeps going again and
again
and then let me go ahead to go to motion
it turns out that under motion there's
this block we haven't seen
point towards the mouse pointer and let
me go ahead and pull this in here
and then let me have it move just like
one step at a time instead of 10.
what is this going to do
what's this program do
yeah say again follow the mouse yeah
this is kind of like a way of taking
their cat
for a walk perhaps not quite the
animal we intended but he'll follow the
cursor and i can actually speed this up
a little bit
so let's have a move ten steps that okay
now there we go
so now he's moving up and down and so
now it's interactive so you might recall
that
um when we were playing oscar time
earlier and picking up the okay
okay don't do that see that's that's a
bug he's just confused he's constantly
moving toward it but you're already
okay so we're gonna stop okay so now
he's following but that's how we might
now create for instance the ability to
move those pieces of trash around and
have them follow the mouse cursor if you
think back to oscar time every time you
picked up a piece of trash it followed
the cursor because there was a forever
loop and a block like this
pointing toward the mouse pointer well
now let's integrate
multiple ideas and actually have
multiple scripts i proposed earlier
that programs can actually have multiple
threads a thread is just a fancy way of
saying in our context
multiple scripts multiple scripts
in one program that are happening
essentially in parallel
computer can effectively do multiple
things at a time thanks to threading
and more on that down the road so these
are more involved but let's see if we
can
let's understand first what this program
does let me go ahead and hit play and
this one
tends to be a little loud
so the sea lion is just barking
endlessly
annoyingly so by reading the code
how can i stop him from barking
hit the space bar all right so hit the
space bar
okay i could just stop the program
obviously but this program's still
running technically
but why did that work well notice this
on the left hand side is the first
script
when the green flag is clicked set this
variable that i called muted to false
could have called it x or y or z or
counter but none of those really makes
sense so i called it muted
and i set it equal to false which is
again a boolean value true or false
just mean yes or no forever if the key
space is pressed
then do this if muted is currently false
then change muted to true else
change muted to false so if muted is
false
change it to true if muted is true
change it to false
anytime the human hits the spacebar
update that variable
now if we look at the other script which
is also driving the c
line what is he doing forever if muted
is false so if he's not muted if muted
is false means not muted
start the sound sea lion and then think
hi hi high for two seconds
and then wait for one more second and
then just repeat repeat repeat but if i
change with the space bar muted to true
he's going to say if muted equals false
that's not so
i'm not going to play a sound this time
and so now we have the ability to
integrate
multiple scripts together in order to
achieve a more interactive
result and what about this um back in uh
when i was a kid might have played over
in the summers
like marco polo super simple game or we
played it in the pool for some reason
where one person in the pool very safely
is blindfolded and then he or she yells
marco
and then everyone around him or her is
supposed to yell polo
and then the person who's blindfolded is
supposed to go chase the other kids in
the pool and tag them and then they
become it
but in other words it's this like
signaling mechanism someone yells marco
and everyone else responds to that
broadcast of the word marco
well it turns out we can simulate this
with these two puppets this guy here
notice that i've highlighted the orange
puppet
because there's a second blue puppet
there separate sprites and these are
just photographs we uploaded to the game
uh forever if the key space
is pressed so if the space bar is
pressed say marco for two seconds
and then broadcast an event meanwhile
the blue puppet here has a super simple
block but it's fundamentally different
from the ones we've seen
he's not starting when the green flag is
clicked he is starting only when he
receives
an event so it turns out that sprites
and scratch can't hear or see
what the other one is saying in those
speech bubbles you have to use a fancier
technique which is this special block
called broadcast
which is like passing a note digitally
from one sprite to another that the
other one can read or receive so to
speak
so only when he receives this event so
to speak does he say
polo for two seconds and again the
orange puppet
sends that secret message just using
this other puzzle piece broadcast
an event like passing a note that the
human doesn't actually see
so if i now hit the green flag and hit
the space bar
orange yells marco blue guy yells polo
in response but those aren't timed
together
rather the blue guy is hearing what the
orange one has said
thereby allowing multiple sprites to
actually
inter-communicate so how did we get here
well recall that we had all these
building blocks a moment ago
first we started out with just functions
and conditions and boolean expressions
and loops we've now added to that
the ability to store information and
variables and threads to do multiple
things at once
and then if you do have multiple things
happening events where they can
intercommunicate
somehow yet another building block so if
we now
take a step back and consider how we can
make
functions of our own we have the final
piece of the puzzle so to speak let me
go ahead and do this
let me go ahead and create a simple
program with when green
flag clicked that simply simulates
coughing for a cat so this cat is going
to say not hello
but cough for one second and then he's
going to go ahead and
wait for one second and then i'm going
to go ahead and copy paste as i
did before this is one of those do as i
say not as i do
to implement this program here where he
coughs three times
we already know though from earlier that
this is not good design why
you're repeating yourself don't repeat
yourself dry as an acronym actually
don't repeat yourself because you're
doing
three times as many times that something
that you only really need to do once
the solution before of course was just
use a loop of some sort so let me
actually take that out
let me use a repeat block change 10 to 3
and then just use two of these blocks
and notice already the program's so much
more compact and now
if i want to change the 3 to a 30 or to
a 10 or any number
i just change one simple value i don't
have to re write or copy paste or delete
things
i can update the program much more
readily and now the same thing is going
to happen
with just cough cough cough but it turns
out that it would be nice to henceforth
abstract away from this right
i just want any program i write to know
how to cough
and coughing is really just saying
something perhaps some number of times
but it turns out we can abstract this
away in code let me go down to my blocks
here
and this allows me to click this button
make a block it allows me to make my own
function
i get this dialog window here and i'm
just going to call this block
cough i'm going to go ahead and click ok
and now i have this new pink block
that itself can have blocks underneath
it and you know what i'm going to do i'm
going to go ahead and do this
i'm going to go ahead and say cough
under there and now notice on the left i
now have access to this new pink
piece i can now put this in here so now
notice
even though yes this is how coughing is
implemented
on the left hand side here next time
when i write a program
i just want to call cough and i don't
care about those lower level
implementation details i don't care
about the binary or any of that i just
want this to be an abstraction
but i could do better than this wouldn't
it be nice if instead of just repeating
cough three times what if i made that a
feature of cough
so let me do this i can go ahead and
right click on this pink piece
and i can edit it that brings up that
same window from before
and notice this add an input so when i
make a custom block i can actually make
pretty fancy blocks just like the ones
mit gives us
with the software and now i can type in
something like n
and if i add a label just to make it
more descriptive i can just say times
so now i've made a special custom puzzle
piece that says cough
some number of times where n for number
is just the go to
variable that programmers tend to use so
now
i can actually move this repeat block
into cough itself but rather than hard
code
three notice this i can steal that
variable and now say
cough this many times by repeating
saying
this again and again and again and now
when i cough in my actual program i just
type in three here
so i have this beautiful abstraction now
so to speak cough this many times and i
and no one else in the world never again
needs to care about what it means to
cough because we've already
implemented that before and so just as
mit has given us so much functionality
that we ourselves don't have to think
about
so can i now make functionality that i
don't have to think about and as we
progress to higher level languages like
c and javascript and python we're going
to continue this process
sometimes solving problems ourselves by
making our own custom puzzle pieces but
very often using things called libraries
code that other humans wrote before us
that's just useful to get the job done
just as scratch has done here in part
for
us let me go ahead then and bring all of
this together
by opening this other example here
let me go ahead and open up this one
which isn't something we've seen
but it's kind of an interactive game
like this made by a former student
should we have an apple yes
[Music]
little animation
okay that didn't end well let's let's
try again
play again and notice the say block is
happening
there's some kind of ask block the
student was checking if the human typed
in yes or no let's type no this time no
apple
oh cupcake okay yes enter
okay don't do that one more life here we
go
okay no apple no cupcake
oh a little variable counting
[Music]
okay so i won the game
[Music]
in our final moments here let me go
ahead and open one
final example as you know cs50 is
offered not only at
harvard but at yale as well so it seems
fitting to perhaps end on a note that
pits one
campus perhaps against the other by way
of another game that a former student
wrote called ivy's hardest game
but for this i think we need one final
volunteer who's comfy coming up okay
first hand wait right there come on down
so in ivy's hardest game it's a game
played with the keyboard
and even though it might look a little
overwhelming at first glance just like
oscar time did and heck just like the
gingerbread animation might
realize that if you decompose it in just
your mind's eye
thinking about what those individual
building blocks are you can probably
guess what the puzzle pieces are hi
what's your name i'm andrea andrea david
nice to meet you
here is ivy's hardest game
we'll pitch you against all of the ivs
here and then right after this we'll be
adjourned
for cupcakes in the transact ready
[Music]
all right a round of applause for andrea
if we could
that's it for cs50 see the website for
details we'll see you for cake in the
transect welcome aboard